CONTROVERSIAL FARM BILL
SUPPORTED BY THE SPEAKER AND OF
THE PRESIDENT.
CHIEF CONGRESSIONAL
CORRESPONDENT MIKE EMANUEL SHOWS
US WHAT HAPPENED.
>> ON THIS BOAT THE EYES ARE 198
AND THE NAMES ARE TO 13.
THE BILL DOES NOT PASS.
>> Reporter: THEY DEFEATED A
FIVE YEAR FARM BILL DEFINING
G.O.P. LEADERS AND
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
THE CONSERVATIVES MINISTRY VOTE
ON A SECURITY FOCUSED
IMMIGRATION PLAN BEFORE THE FARM
BILL, WITH SOME REPUBLICANS
SIGNING ON WITH DEMOCRATS TO
FORCE A VOTE ON ADDRESSING, DACA
IT BECAME AN EMERGENCY.
>> I WOULD SAY IT DOESN'T EXPIRE
UNTIL SEPTEMBER SO WE HAVE
PLENTY OF TIME TO DEAL WITH IT,
BUT WE COULD BE DEALING WITH IT
NEXT MONTH.
SO IT'S MORE IMPORTANT RIGHT NOW
TO PRIORITIZE IMMIGRATION AND WE
HAVE BEEN ASKING AND WAITING FOR
MONTHS.
>> Reporter: HOUSE G.O.P.
LEADERS PUT THE FARM BILL ON THE
FLOOR CALLING THEIR BLUFF.
THE PACKAGE INCLUDES POLICY
CHANGES FAVORED BY THE PRESIDENT
AND THE SPEAKER INCLUDING HAVING
ABLE-BODIED FOOD STAMP
RECIPIENTS WORK OR RECEIVE JOB
TRAINING.
THE BILL CAN BE BROUGHT UP AGAIN
WHEN THE LEADERSHIP IS CONFIDENT
THEY HAVE A VOTE.
>> SURE IT'S DISAPPOINTING, WE
NEED TO MOVE FORWARD ON THE FARM
BILL AND THE REPUBLICANS WANT TO
MOVE FORWARD ON THE REFORM FOR
THE FOOD STAMP PROGRAM.
>> THE FOOD CAMP, EXAM PROGRAM
KEPT THEM UNIFIED ON THE FARM
BILL.
TOP DEMOCRATS SAY EASING THE
WORK REQUIREMENTS COULD HELP
DELIVER VOTES FROM HIS SIDE.
>> THE WHOLE PROBLEM WAS FOOD
STAMPS.
IT COULD HAVE BEEN WORKED OUT.
I'M NOT HAPPY THAT THIS FAILED.
YOU KNOW, I'M NOT HAPPY WE ARE
IN THIS SITUATION, BUT I AM
WILLING TO DO WHAT I CAN TO TRY
TO FIX IT.
>> Reporter: AT THE
WHITE HOUSE SAYS THE PRESIDENT